each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hmm when I was taking my daughter to
school I told him that I got to spend
the afternoon with david brin and my
daughter Alexandra said cool earth is an
awesome book she's 12 years old I
figured you know I have to say I was
awfully proud of her at that very moment
we're very fortunate david brin with us
this afternoon for those of you who
followed his books which of one Hugo and
nebula awards as well as several other
mentions of distinction he through much
of his recent writing he's been talking
about the surveillance society in which
such as Earth and killed people and in
fact he's written a book of nonfiction
lately called the transparent society
really talking about more of the same
issues around surveillance is that one
of the things that I've always
appreciate about his work is not only
does he just draw vivid descriptions of
dystopic societies in the future but the
people in his books never just take it
sitting down there always sort of take
thoughtful responses to it to try to
arrest of the problems to the ground and
so for the next hour 45 minutes hours so
David's going to share with some his
thoughts from from his writings about
what we should be doing to try to
wrestle some of these problems with
surveillance asides the ground so please
join me welcoming David Brent thanks
Kevin I think I think this this bike is
I'm not not restricted to their nice to
be back at Microsoft I was just a night
before last giving a talk to keynote the
launching of paul allen's new
environmental organization the global
solutions institute which is doing in
combination with UC Santa Barbara last
night I gave a book reading at the
science fiction museum which I hope you
have all patronized with Greg bear your
local hero or local
hero as the case may be he's a fellow
killer beasts I can say that the we
didn't have very good attendance because
a few hundred meters away Michael Moore
was at the key arena and one could hear
all the way through all the walls and in
the liquid lounge all through all the
drums in the liquid round we could hear
the laughter from from several hundred
meters away through the walls of the key
arena so he's he's quite a showman well
we're in interesting times aren't we i
long ago believed that magic the
difference between magic and science is
because magic is based upon incantations
and subjective reality science is about
trying to corner objective reality now
great sages throughout history have
always said Jesus Buddha Socrates they
all said in Plato's allegory of the cave
you cannot know what's real you cannot
know what's real because your senses are
imperfect everything isn't perfect
bringing you the messages of what this
is you can't know and that is first
statement is wise and it should have led
to humility and good stuff but then they
always copped out and then said so give
up and search and get real truth through
incantations incantations of faith
incantations of logic incantations of
meditation get truth from my prescribed
method of incantation because the real
world is helpless until Galileo came
along and said you're right I can't know
what this is perfectly my senses are
flawed I I color what I see by what I
want to see I can lie to myself the one
phrase that can save your marriage
the one fake face that can start a
marriage I can lie to myself but by
comparing notes with others by doing
experiments by measurements and
comparing what's all everybody can find
about this we can corner objective
reality which none of us can ever see
and I can not find out what this is but
I can find out a whole lot of things
that it's not and by carving away what
it's not we can make some progress now
this led eventually to something
empirical called the Enlightenment off
also called modernism and in my opinion
that's where the war is right now forget
the left/right political axis I mean for
God's sake do you know anybody who can
define it you've been satisfied defining
yourself on something that you can't
even define for heaven's sake if for no
other reason abandon it because it's
French it groups together Odd Couple
alliances that have nothing to do with
each other and it makes us completely
ignore the real cultural war that's cuts
through every single one of these groups
and that is are they romantics or are
they believers in progress in science in
the Enlightenment in negotiated
pragmatism wherever you see incantations
prescribed as answers to why humans are
the way they are then you're seeing the
same thing that made the 20th century a
pit of hell you know they had the best
of intentions sometimes the idiot logs I
mean in the first half of the 20th
century it really looked to them as a
lot of them as if Marxism had an
explanation for what was wrong with
humanity in an answer to how humanity
can be happy a lot of very sincere
people but it was one more set of
incantations now it has anything had
happened a hundred years before people
turned two nations after they got sick
of their priests and kings well
certainly before and certainly after
world war one people were sick of the
nations which had led them into hell and
so they get started giving their fealty
to ideologies and dogmas and simplistic
prescriptions and models of the world
and the last 50 years we've been clawing
our way out of this solving problems
pragmatically was it ideology that ended
racism or a people pragmatically
deciding that doesn't make any sense
we're denying ourselves capabilities of
people who have been squashed and having
their ability to compete ruined because
of something that makes no sense I mean
what was it that God art show our
daughters out there doing karate my
ten-year-old daughter is a year away
from her black belt she's delayed
because she suddenly got a crush on
Michael Phelps and she's swimming like
mad to get into the 2018 olympics I roll
my eyes and say all right but you're
still going to get learn how to kill
I mean the feminists who want those
feminists who wanted us to become you
know gelded but good looking like
commander Riker on Star Trek they were
doomed to disappointment we're all
descendants of the guys and got harems
you cannot control what we think I
cannot control what I think those
religions who say that thinking it is
doing it there are no males in heaven
when we go down to the beach my wife
gives it me wraparound sunglasses and
says don't drool you guys know you can't
control your thoughts but you can with
great deal of agonized effort control
your actions you can control what you do
and then the great argument with the
play tennis with Plato and all that
we've finally discovered that what you
do is more important than what you think
your actions that may help change the
world and make them better are more
important than your stupid theories as
to why and I'm talking to myself to look
I'm not paid to be right I'm paid to be
interesting every prior see human
civilization that ever existed would
have burned a guy like me at the stake
very quickly I wake up every morning
that Cossacks have not burned by home I
start out loyal I'm grateful to her
civilization that instead pays me to
blather rather than burdens me for it
and that's what we all should be we all
should be at least somewhat burnable
don't you think I mean that's your
fundamental loyalty to this culture is
to be at least a little bit burnable
well you know I've been getting a lot of
attention because of the transparent
Society will technology force us to
choose between freedom and privacy now
some of this stuff was discussed in my
novel earth that was a little bit my
book for grown-ups you know very intense
near future
all sorts of stuff going on and I talked
about privacy and secrecy in that one
you know in the future that I portray an
earth the people of 20-40 look back 20
years before to the horrible war that
they had waged nuclear war of the entire
world against Switzerland it took three
years several million lives the glarus
alps were reduced to slag but we finally
got the bank records think how the world
would be different if every bank account
was simply open it no confiscation just
everybody knew what everybody owned now
a great many rich people would be
embarrassed but if they got it fairly
what's the real harm I get a little
radical sometimes but it's not left and
right the point is you know I'm
sometimes portrayed as this anti privacy
guy but actually I'm really quite
moderate privacy is nice privacy is good
I like my privacy but I can see we're
entering a 21st century sometimes called
Bryn's corollary on moore's law every
two years the camera cameras get smaller
more acute cheaper and more mobile at a
rate that matches Moore's law now what
the heck are you going to do about that
within 10 years your children will be
buying stickers you know those roles of
stickers and they will be penny cams
each with their own ipv6 URL and they'll
stick them on walls anywhere they want
what are you going to do in a world of
penny cams what are you going to do in a
world it was the biologists succeed at
doing to their labs with the
cyberneticists did to the room sized
computers putting them on everybody's
desktop including pimple-faced a
socialized but brilliant teenagers who
proceeded to invent by
mrs. what's going to happen when the
quotation marks go away when Amalek you
Mack on your on your desktop I really
should rephrase that here on your
desktop can synthesize any known or
unknown organic compound or any of you
ever going to eat food served by
resentful teenagers at McDonald's our
only hope will be a that robots take
over in remote Donald's and that would
suit the trend good gross labor should
be done by machines or the ratio of
social socialized and responsible
pimple-faced brilliant teenagers hackers
remains and grows much larger than the
ratio of those who are homicidal jerks
it's that ratio that we absolutely count
on for to prevent Thomas prick for
Thomas Friedman called the super
empowerment of the angry young man he by
the way has just joined the rats
deserting the sinking ship go look at
the latest issue of american
conservative magazine by the way i mean
the the number of conservative
commentators in the last two weeks of
all the sudden jump ship is staggering
george will just jumped pat pat buchanan
it's amazing but thomas friedman spoke
of the super empowerment of the angry
young man the dispersal of the power to
harm through technological means is
going to continue during the next 20-30
years the only thing that can save us is
by making sure that education spreads
like mad but that also includes your
ability use these things so you've also
got to include throughout the world a
larger share that most of these bright
young people are stakeholders that they
feel the expression that i often ask
people to say aloud to themselves it's
on my bumper iaam OAC i am
member of a civilization one that
deserves my loyalty there's a little
thing I was doing is this a sharpie I
shouldn't write on here with a sharpie
here's one I was just in the other room
pointing out what I think should our
flag should be and our flag should be
this in all of human history most ever
since every time that metallurgy and
agriculture were discovered some guys
would pick up metal metal implements and
take other men's women and wheat hey
guys it's what a lot of you would do you
know look inside your hearts I try to be
one of the good kings a few learning and
over ignorant masses below and there are
a lot of people in our civilization who
yearn for this they would yearn for this
instead of this because you feel more
rich in a poorer pyramid then you feel
rich at the top of a dynamic rising
diamond in which the well-off outnumber
the poor and so you can't have really
really serve I'll servants because if it
because Bill Gates has to pay his
servants so much that within 10 years
they have servants now if you like that
being a member of a civilization like
that fine the point is it's only when
this happened and the well-off
outnumbered the poor that you hear any
mentions of eliminating poverty because
it becomes a bitter Lake and therefore
somebody's fault rather than a vast sea
that's like an act of nature which is
how they looked at poverty and other
civilizations now this is astonishing in
its implications and there are people up
at the top of this diamond who get it
who get it and they don't mind the fact
that everybody else is going to get the
same toys they have right now in a
couple of years part of their pleasure
is getting those toys
just a year or two before everybody else
while giving back to the civilization
enough so that no child inherits this
position it's not illegal for somebody
to have bad luck or make bad decisions
and be poor but it's wrong for their
children to inherit such a position they
should all become engineers the value
systems that the civilization is
developing are different than any other
value system if you take a look at those
pyramidal cultures and you see that the
romantic worldview was promulgated in
all of them it has certain basic themes
nostalgia things were better in the past
if there was a golden age it was in the
past apprenticeship is better than
professions masters masters student is
better than universities the rural is
better than the urban see this
mythologized in in jr Tolkien
hierarchical social orders quality as a
human being is inherited by right of
blood Star Wars ours is the first
civilization that has taken the notion
of a golden age and put it in a future
that we might build or more likely that
our children might build if we so equip
them the fundamental premise of science
fiction is that children might learn
from the mistakes of their parents and
that's what makes it different than
fantasy in fantasy it is good that there
is a feudal order and it will remain a
feudal order that's why I'm McCaffrey
does not write fantasy how many of you
were read her dragon books within the
context of a feudal social order and she
likes the bards and she likes the
weaving and she likes all that stuff but
within the series they eventually find
out that they had fallen from a high
civilization that had spaceships flush
toilets printing presses constitutions
in the germ theory of disease and they
want them back as fast as possible and
that what is what makes for feudal
setting dragons and all that sort of
thing science
fiction you judged these stories by the
want what do you want how bet most of
you want your children to be better than
you you assume that it's possible for
them to be better than you and that's a
killer to every Dogma because dogmas are
incantations of absolute truth but but
but if your children can be better than
you then what other goal can you have
except to do whatever is pragmatic using
right-handed solutions left-handed
solutions whatever pragmatically will
achieve the goal of having four billion
really really bright children on this
planet if that's achieved by whatever
means will get us there then they'll be
smarter than us and they don't need our
freaking dogmas they'll figure it out
for themselves it's not our job as
Gramps to tell them what to do it's our
job to get them there pragmatists get
this argument romantic dogmatists don't
and that's what that's what I think the
war is right now I think that you see an
awful lot of elements left right center
foreign who really want modernism to
fail and for a long time the left was
ranting against is that you ever heard
of post-modernism the philosophy that
everything's relative nothing can be
verified nothing bright pragmatic
science is irrelevant they've they
launched full-tilt assaults on modernism
from four decades this is not all the
left mind you it is the romantic left
and right now we see all three seats of
government in the United States
controlled by romantics of the right
that is about the softest terminology I
could use
my point in the transparent society is
that none of us likes accountability to
be applied to ourselves given a choice
between accountability and privacy we
always like privacy for ourselves and
accountability for our enemies but when
you get right down to it in all of human
history I'm reading Jared Diamond's new
book collapse anybody heard of Jared
Diamond he wrote Guns Germs and Steel
genius real curmudgeon you know those of
you who are in the game end of I'd like
to talk to you afterwards you know I i
wrote a game with him and all of a
sudden he changes his mind oh well you
know you put up with your geniuses I'm
reading and reviewing his new book
collapse which isn't on the market yet
and he discusses in the rise and fall of
civilizations from an ecological point
of view which is vastly more intelligent
than the Toynbee oh they were young and
vigorous and their middle age and then
they'll ended it is senescence and
decline been rude but in my opinion the
ecological explanations are a subset of
one simple thing is your civilization
agile enough and smart enough to notice
what's going wrong and do whatever it
takes to save your children but to me
that's the fundamental thing what I
believe is that there has only been
discovered one antidote to error and
that's with something called criticism
and the great irony that explains most
of human history in just one line is
human beings hate criticism and if
you're a powerful leader you have the
power to suppress criticism criticism is
dangerous for your position in power
even though it is the one thing that you
need in order to engage in good
statecraft good steak raft and a leaders
security in power smug security and
power our encounter
failing interests and most civilizations
because the leaders were in charge chose
this approach 200 years ago under
Franklin and Washington we chose this
one they deliberately chose a form of
government that made life very difficult
for them during Washington's
administration when he was revered my
hero George Marshall wrote I I am
dedicated to democracy and worship it
though I suffer from it daily our
leaders should suffer this game is not
about them and where the first human
civilization that has ever mastered not
mastered but have a grip on the notion
of how to keep elites accountable how do
we do that I'm a mythologist I'm right
mythology even though I'm an anti
romantic I still use romantic imagery
and things like that in my novels I
believe in mythology plays a large role
in it do you believe your fellow
citizens are subjected to propaganda
everybody always nods and I'm going to
cut to the chase here because we don't
have much time I asked people named
propaganda and oh the people are led
like sheep to buy stuff no religion no
this and that or the other and it's
always something that the speaker feels
not me you never call propaganda a
message that you believe but contempt
for the masses is a drug we all engage
in you and your pals have a better idea
what's going on than their masses out
there come on everybody Mia culpa that's
what you do it's the most natural human
thing in the world and you really should
be suspicious about it because what were
we talking about the beginning I can
fool myself
without a doubt the most relentless
propaganda campaign in human history has
been suspicions of authority you have
not seen a popular film in which the
main character doesn't bond with the
audience in the first five minutes by
sticking it to an authority figure you
want the bonding to be a little closer
have that lead character show or express
or manifest tolerance in some way and
show or a manifest some harm harmless
eccentricity those three messages you'd
be hard put to find a movie in which the
bad guy is not set up for his eventual
fall by committing some act of
intolerance or suppression of harmless
eccentricity or acting like a snooty
authority figure these three messages
are the major propaganda messages in our
culture and we don't notice them as
propaganda because we agree now why do
you agree maybe didn't get immunity
because you suckled these messages all
your life now do I have trouble parsing
this all the way through to the
committee of fat old cigar-chomping men
in a dark teak paneled room who say
we're going to put out propaganda
messages that the people should be
suspicious of authority figures antique
handled rooms I don't have explanations
for everything but it is weird and it
shows that we need to think the
difference we did a good decent Democrat
and a good decent Republican and a good
decent libertarian is mostly how these
well trained Americans decide which is
the authority figure they worry about a
decent Democrat is worried about
accumulations of undue conspiratorial
power by conniving aristocrats and
faceless corporations a decent
Republican is worried about snooty
academics and faceless government
bureaucrats
uh the libertarian picks one from Co man
come on from gonna be when expressed
that way what's the most beautiful great
word in the English language that
philosophically answers what I just said
duh human cheaters will go wherever the
shadows are and if they can be
commissars they'll be commissars if
they'll suck up to an aristocracy the
portion of the aristocracy that wants
the pyramid then they'll do that and you
got to decide in any generation in any
decade which is the ramparts of freedom
that are under assault and I'll give you
a hint it ain't commies you got just got
a gut be agile it is only an agile human
civilization that can deal with threats
that can take a blow like 911 and do
what needs to be done in a professional
way while going back to their lives
instead keeping our armed forces ready
for emergencies instead of in ensnaring
them in a land war in Asia that has got
our readiness right now at lower levels
than Pearl Harbor this is not smart in
dangerous times I have written about
this um but you didn't come here to get
a political rant what you got here two
came here to get was theory so before we
move over to signing books and letting
you guys stand up and how let me which
believe it or not i'd enjoy i'm going to
show a couple of other things that I've
been working on one is um did are any of
the comic book there the graphic novel
no all right well I'll pass this around
it's the cover to my new graphic novel
and those of you who like can get
bookplates for it so you can buy it
later
but it's really cool graphic novel based
on a novella of mine that came in second
for a Hugo about 10 years ago that's
just the cover you might have heard of
Thor meets Captain America a novella
that's takes a very weird theory that
after that probably is true that the
Nazis were trying to do
industrial-strength necromancy while
killing people fifty fifty percent of
human cultures practice necromancy the
belief that death is the most powerful
source of magic so why wouldn't they
they were killing them anyway and so in
this world they succeed they call up the
Norse gods and we're in real bad trouble
so it's a very beautifully painted by
the artist Scott Hampton what else have
I been engaged and I've been trying to
invent a new form of online chat venture
capitalists are like movie producers now
in bit now nowadays the best answer is
always you never get fired for saying no
if only this were the 90s
could say that in about a dozen
different ways um so what else I'm going
to show you something really cool in a
minute it's an online game that was
inspired by your local science fiction
museum I'm on the board of advisers in
fact i'm attending a party there tonight
hosted by your own paul allen in which
believe it or not i have to fork out
over money because i'm a member of the
board of advisers and they want to say
we want to say that all of our board of
advisors are members of the holo deck
circle it's a great job it's a great
museum you know it's a wonderful thing
we were terribly surprised when we found
out that everything zooms down to books
you go to the eye candy you see the
wonderful weapons and your I drifts down
to a little area down below where there
are books and they talk about the ideas
it's what we asked for you know we
didn't ask for an equal time in volume
or cost just let the I glide towards
some books it's great it's wonderful I
I'm very disappointed that the wall of
weapons doesn't have the ZF one though
anybody know what the ZF one is Gary
Oldman in the fifth element ZF one it's
good for righties and lefties you
remember that 00 people ask me what my
favorite science fiction films are and I
say where my dials set I even go to see
Lucas Films but I set my morality as
well as my adulthood and critical
faculty dials 20 and then I rip out the
wires just about the only films that I
go to that I did that is 0 out morality
going to the fifth element I properly
zeroed out common sense
and then i SAT there and I let the
director simply pour his joy I mean how
those have you seen it have you ever
seen anybody happier than the director
of that movie you guys are paying me to
do this so I'm not gonna let you down
look at this no look at this look at
this how does it might I'll get back to
that stuff I'll get back to all that
stuff the first and Arya this goes to
show you gotta have it let it be
flexible he can't be snooty intellectual
all the time being a flexible and
adaptable human civilization has got to
be what is what is about and as the more
as the corollary to Moore's law can
continues as the cameras move get more
and more in the world as databases keep
more track of us we have to take a look
at the eyeglasses notebooks I glasses
and books are fundamentally multiple
ottoman tations of human vision and
memory where monkeys we want to see we
want to know human memory was capable in
the old village of knowing the names I
faces identities and reputations of a
thousand to four thousand people four
thousand if you were the guy who was
gregarious and was sent with the cart to
the nearby town where you could make
deals by handshake by reputation
remember his latest Shakespeare the
worst thing to happen to a man was to be
forsworn because his reputation would go
to hell we are exactly the same only our
reputation is artificially and
prosthetic Lee augmented with all these
things they substitute for the handshake
level reputation well when you're
walking down the street in the future
and a corner lens in the corner of your
glasses is scanning everybody's faces as
they go by and looking about not
necessarily government just any old
database finding out who they are and
then writing their names
every person is going by maybe putting a
little flair image if they might have a
worrisome reputation but the first
couple of lines of their preening net
presa phase or dissenting opinions from
their ex-spouse depending on how you
tuned your glasses they're dating
profiles passed by a beautiful woman see
a dating profile oh she looks at you
bursts out laughing there's a French
phrase guys pusa Sean's clue Salem em
shows the more things stay the same the
point is you'll be able to go to a
tinker in Bangkok and say sis but your
curio shop in Duluth like some of these
and he's tapping and he's looking at at
your your sisters accounts and you and
all that and he says I can deliver 12 by
next Thursday can you shake your hands
on both of your glasses of witnessed it
and you walk away the village is coming
back we have no choice the village is
coming back these cities their anonymity
there were some pleasures to them but
also loneliness the question is not
whether or not the village is coming
back but which village because there's
some pretty awful things about those old
villages local patrician families
controlling the cops and the judges
local gossips and busybodies invading
your lives and invading your privacy and
and and threatening you all the time
Reed Babbitt take a look at nineteen
eighty-four which is the great big
village of the state with its telescreen
that can look down at you but you cannot
look back but the village it doesn't
have to be like that look at Andy Hardy
movies mickey rooney & judy garland
where individual excess tricity
everybody's individual eccentricity is
respected and sure the poor family the
dad's lost his job the mom's sick what
is the response
alright so they know about it I know
let's put on a show well it beats some
futures if you find a way that you can
ban the cameras let me know because
right now as high mine said the chief
thing accomplished by privacy laws is to
make the bugs smaller you showed me how
and I'm willing to listen but so far I
haven't seen even one of the biometrics
even one of the cameras even one of the
techniques that anybody has proposed a
method of banning them that would work
and that's one and there are thousands
so what I'm going to do quick before we
open it up for questions is i'm going to
show you what i put up here on the
internet something completely different
and now for something completely
different is it going oh we're gonna
mausam come on that's a screensaver oh
okay i guess it's not on that one well
you're welcome to oh well the XO areum
is just one of the projects that has
been taking me from writing a novel
during the last three years my wife
keeps telling me all these other
projects of yours will even if they're
successful will be extinct and all that
would be left a hundred years from now
is your books and she's completely right
and my bank account is telling me I
adore do this too because so far so far
this is my effort with a famous tech
artist named Sheldon Brown we met
through our daughters actually he did
the wall of tvs at the Seattle Center
down here he's a world-renowned tech
artist and he's head of the effort down
at UCSD to create a new college within
UCSD that defies CP snows declaration
that two cultures will never meet
because it is specifically aimed at tech
art at combining art and science and
this is um our notion for how to get
either museum exhibit because we were
inspired by the science fiction museum
or an online game that would be
fantastically educational while at the
same time exciting fun and possibly a
moneymaker the the notion is well Steve
Jackson games made a game out of my
uplift universe in his in his group's
role-playing system in which he used
dice and I spent a lot of time because
I'd been around the contact people on
I'm the one science fiction author on
the study committees you know if we if
contact is made you know I'll be dragged
off into the night but but but the point
is that what that was with a dice
rolling system where you would choose a
star choose a solar
choose a planet and an ecology and work
your way on up and develop using some
plausible statistics and odds develop a
sapient life-form including its
personality that would largely result
from for instance where it was on the
food chain how paranoid it would be and
things like that well the xor ian is an
attempt to to take that off the page and
dice and all of that let's see now and
you know do I just simply go press the
there is no narration but is this the
arrow I want down here or up here how do
I get it to move along try the numbers
all the numbers yeah that'd that'd do it
wouldn't it all right well there's our
miles and there's what he does what I do
have these see my children won't ever
have to wear these nobody ever pities me
I had 47 years of perfect eyesight okay
well what you do is at the creation
stations is phase one where you create a
solar system you create a planet and
then an ecosystem and then the
individual sapient life-forms and then
when that is done and it's done in a
museum environment or the online game
it's done in two levels one is do you
really want to get involved in the
science fine let's do the fine tuning
but there are great big red buttons in
the front of all these things for busy
days and when kids are going around
because if you've ever been to a place
like the Explorer X exploratorium and
stuff like that they really want quick
results dang you chose a hot star it'll
have a wide life zone you know but you
better not get too close bang you chose
a water world you may not get hands on
fire you know stuff like that but also
offering other people the chance to
develop these life-forms and at the very
end you get spewed out a ticket with a
barcode and a unique URL in cyberspace
where your alien now lives your alien
species now lives forever the thing
you've created is now a safety until I
form there in inner space and then here
is the medium-sized second phase which
is the XO areum the extra-terrestrial
terrarium because you are then invited
to bring your creation down to the
extra-terrestrial terrarium to have
encounters with other alien species or
with humans so you know where was i five
i think i am at five so we'll just zoom
along through some of the boring look
the distance can it be in alien City so
new and some of the new graphic
rendering systems can can render these
things very very efficient efficiently
and very quickly so you replicate
evolution at the creation stations guide
and modify it maybe uplift an alien
civilization one touch creation that's
vivid for kids you can on the online
game it can be different different
levels of the game for kids and of
course that includes different levels of
violence sophisticated stages for this
patient and savvy and your any culture
coded forever and I think that is eight
and the most lavish version is that
would take the most museum space is you
do your creation stations um you need to
use this that the other rim overlooking
the galactic center and then you're
invited to take your creation down down
notorious voice as stars and holographic
images flash running down down into the
galactic center you bring your alien
race can do they have what it takes to
match their metal in the terrarium and
the big XO airing down the middle of how
many of you have ever seen silent
running the movie silent running with
all its domes in all directions well you
bringing a chlorine life-form down okay
so then out swings one of these domes
and fills the dome of the XO areum so i
just thought i'd entertain you with a
little bit of less of a ramped than i've
been giving you because i know very well
that
I know very well that some of you might
resent that part go thou forth and
defend your democracy as you see fit but
do bear in mind that the axes the
political axes that we are encouraged to
divide ourselves along may not be at
right for an agile 21st century you see
unlike a lot of the liberal opponents to
what's going on right now I actually
believe in pax americana some of the
things that these neoconservatives are
saying I think they're true I just think
that they're imbeciles Pax Americana is
the last rest hope for Humanity we can
under vente intervene to get rid of a
bastard dictators I think that that if
there's going to be a decent Humanity in
the middle of the century we're going to
have to pave the way many many things of
these things I really but these guys are
maniacs and and they don't deserve to be
in charge of that go across purposes to
the things you're being told that you
have to believe I mean look at this we
have had a 20th century that was based
upon a monotonic increase in the degree
to which we have relied upon skilled
professionals to do things that we used
to do for ourselves now there's a little
bit of shame attached to that but
there's an awful lot of pleasure Paul
Allen has strawberries flown in from
from New Zealand every winter for him
and I have strawberries flown in every
winter for me too I like that I like
being a member of the civilization in
which i only pay twice as much for
strawberries during winter as I do
during spring it's great and I like
having skilled professionals out there
trying to protect me and by the way they
all failed on 911 not one of the actions
I have an essay about this at David Brin
com by David Brin calm it's a
cornucopia
look at the essay David Britt not even
citizens ascendant at David Brin com
where I and this one woman at the boston
globe were the only ones to point this
out that every single action that did
any good that day without exception was
performed by private individuals armed
with the very same technologies that
pundits keep telling us are going to
enslave us all the video footage all the
documentation all the calls that said I
don't care what the emergency operators
are telling you about staying at your
desk get out and the rebellion on you a
93 every even the firefighting because
the brave firefighters the professionals
charged into the buildings and died
everything was done by amateurs that day
and that's why we have had no further
attacks because every time every
generation the would who hate
our civilization have to rationalize why
they can take us on and what is their
rationalization we're rich we're happy
we have to have paid something in the
trade off the famous trade off the
devil's dichotomy we have to have paid
something and so they always tell
themselves we paid with our manhood
we're decadent we're soft and the reason
why there haven't been any more attacks
is because that's not we didn't panic we
went right forth and did an incredibly
by partisans piece of success with
clinton's planning and bushes saying go
get em boys and we did incredible job in
afghanistan and to this date were the
first people to go there since Alexander
the Great who still think our managed
can manage to fool ourselves a couple of
years later that we aren't in pain the
first time has it happened in 2,500
years a lot of people don't realize that
the planning for that campaign was
for more than a year before hand but the
point is that this ever increasing
reliance on skilled professionals can't
go on look at the curve at the rate that
it's been taking place we would need an
American population of 20 billion people
all of them professionals one of the
things I try to point out in the
transparent society is that the answer
is already burgeoning what I call the
age of amateurs and we have to create a
civilization that empowers people to
self-organize and become the kind of
amateurs who can handle a future that
rushes at us with surprise because these
wispy little prefrontal lobes above our
eyes these are what we use to probe into
the future the Bible refers to Moses
having lamps on his brow and this was
mistranslated again and again as horns
so all the medieval images including
that wonderful sculpture of Michelangelo
of Moses show Moses with horns but the
lamps on the brow these are the
prefrontal lobes that we use for
gedanken experiments for thought
experiments for foresight for looking
into the future and whenever they get
sniped in prefrontal lobotomies people
who's all interested in the future which
is why I'd much rather have a free
bottle in front of me than a prefrontal
lobotomy but the point is the point is
that this is what enables it us to do
Einstein's gedanken experiments
exploring the potential futures and we
have to get better at it we have to get
better at it with tools like you're
providing for data acquisition and data
analysis and with mental tools a people
who are strong and sovereign and agile
and independent minded and able to say
all right you be suspicious of authority
of the left I'll be suspicious of
authority to the right and I don't think
that you're being suspicious of
authority of the left is evil no you're
guarding my back da
if we can start thinking that way
instead of screaming at people who are
our allies have the same basic instinct
as us then I think there's a real good
chance that we can make it and I believe
guys like you are a large part of the
solution why would i not think so you're
about to buy a bunch of my books Thanks
can we help tonight with some questions
02 two questions are questions are
fetching anybody I have this effect on
people yeah there's a pocket focus on we
sound like the correspondence a
corollary of integrity a far more
interested in maintaining integrity that
I am worried about privacy and I quite
agree with you and it considered my job
as a parent to instill pregnant
integrity into my children but most
civilizations that preached at people be
good have no effect whatsoever on the
worst of us the thing you see me I want
you to know that you're seeing me and
not somebody else pretending to be me I
understand that but what I'm saying is
the thing that has worked in our
civilization against the worst cheaters
has been something called accountability
I mean Rodney King was a step in
accountability Abu Ghraib you took their
own damn pictures I mean you know we're
learning that accountability on elites
is one thing accountability on doofuses
you can often count on them themselves
the second question second and last all
right I'm going to meet you guys over
there and thanks a lot keep up the good
work
you